with Josh backing out we were
disappointed unquestionably we were
disappointed and surprised we'd agreed
to contract terms I got a call Tuesday
evening saying he had decided to he
changed his mind and was going in a
different direction the rivalry is back
on as everybody Chris bailed the Colts
Jim after being jilted by josh mcdaniels
after Super Bowl 52 and the Colts
attitude at the time battled his
attitude was hey I'd rather find out now
then after he's been here for a year
that's all right what
what if josh mcdaniels had ultimately
honored his commitment to take that job
shown up in indy been the coach of the
Colts
what would the cult's have done last
year what was your views on the Colts be
as of right now as a as a viable NFL
franchise you know I don't know if they
would be a whole lot different than
where they are really I mean I really
you know again I'm a guy that's I'm a
huge Josh McDaniels fan I mean I think
he's one of the best offensive minds in
the sport the last 1012 years in
football so you know I respect him so
much that way to where yeah I think with
you know the the some of the pieces they
have in place would that offensive line
in his system yes different than Frank
Reich certainly but I mean and we know
every bit is it effective and has
answers for everything and creative as
can be so I I think if like Josh
McDaniels from the what-if aspect for
the Colts I go I think the results would
have been very similar I think we saw a
team that's probably in the wild-card
game and who knows what happens there
what do you feel there Mike I mean the
big question with me is where what
happens to Frank Reich if we go the what
if part of this and that's where I I'm
interested to hear that to Frank Reich
wasn't even on anyone's radar screen as
a head coaching candidate right for last
cycle
he wasn't he wasn't interviewed he
wasn't considered by the Colts that this
is the ultimate holy crap what do we do
our guy backed out hey how about the
offensive coordinator from the team that
actually won the Super Bowl right not
that guy yeah and I don't know what
would have happened last year
what would the with the Eagles have been
good enough
last year to inject Frank Reich into
that discussion for a guy who should be
a head coach would he have a team of his
own right now I feel I don't know I feel
like he would you know again just
because of the whole you know again this
is not a young guy but he's not an old
guy by any stretch of the imagination
but the offensive guru quarterback
whisperer factor hey Chris yes Chris
Chris yeah you know what you know where
Frank Reich would have been very
intriguing Green Bay Packers yes I think
that's where he would have been that's
where I was going with this I mean I
think that's what the what-if factor is
that jumped out to me I think if you
made me just looking at crystal ball and
go okay Josh McDaniels went to
Indianapolis Colts are good everything's
great Frank Reich had him stay in
Philadelphia one more year we're gonna
rave about the job he did with Carson
Wentz oh no one's got hurt and man foals
was ready to go again and we'll rave
about that and I do I look at all the
job openings that came available and I
look at Green Bay as being that one
there where I go oh that that makes
sense and hey he was an Andy Reid you
know he's from the coaching tree of the
Andy Reid tree there under Doug Peterson
and Andy Reid worked in Green Bay I just
think I'm with you there Mike I think he
ends up there and he's the head coach of
the Packers right now and I also think
that as a career backup quarterback and
he did have his moments he was the guy
who was on the field for one of the
greatest comebacks we will ever see in
football the bills went over the Oilers
in the playoffs 26 years ago now but I I
think Reich would have been the perfect
guy to work with Aaron Rodgers because I
think Reich number one has no ego and
that's a that's a good quality when
you're dealing with players who have
massive egos I think Reich would be the
one to push the buttons and all know
that you can push Aaron Rodgers but you
have to kind of let gently graze his
buttons you know he can't know that his
buttons are being pushed he's smart
enough yeah and but right right whatever
it would have taken to get the most out
of Aaron Rodgers you know I'd never
thought about this before just now I
think Reich would be the perfect guy to
do it may be the ultimate losers to you
know the this this outcome with Josh
McDaniels not following through on his
commitment to
the cult's is the Green Bay Packers
because they possibly have Frank Reich
right now yeah I mean that's that's
where it led me to believe because you
know you know we get this and we get the
rundown last night and I'm thinking what
if Wednesday okay the Colts yeah all
right man I don't know if a whole lot
would be different there I mean I think
a lot of Chris yeah do the Patriots win
the Super Bowl last year without josh
mcdaniels now that would have thrown
that woulda that's like the big wrinkle
and the question because of what they
did last year too and kind of
transforming their style of play right
to where they became me you know to back
one tight end twenty one team personnel
where they wanted to run the ball and
pull guards and do all that stuff and
Bri created that way to where yeah I
don't know if a new OC in New England
would have came in and implemented that
type of game plan and would be able to
coach the different style of play quite
to the abilities Josh McDaniel says I
mean that's why josh is so valued in New
England
he's like an extension of Belichick and
that that's a big question there Mike I
mean I don't know if I feel confident in
saying they would definitely be at the
Super Bowl with if Josh McDaniels wasn't
wasn't there I don't know it would have
been it would have been a Chiefs Rams
rematch in Atlanta could have been
enough right yeah if and and and look
not that Super Bowl 53 was boring
because no Super Bowl is truly boring
but as Super Bowls go that was born was
born yeah would have been a little bit
different maybe if it would have been
chiefs and rams and I think that's what
it would have been if McDaniels had
stayed in Indy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports